[Music]
yeah thanks everybody um my name is Bala
this is my colleague Aram and we're
working for Royal Flora Holland which is
uh in fact the biggest uh uh flower
auctioning uh Marketplace in the world
and it is located in almeir amongst
other places who are we I'm Bal Hendrick
I work at Royal Flora itself
so uh Adam bash here I work at CB data
one of our recruiters are is already
sitting here if you're interested later
on I worked there as a machine learning
engineer for two and a half years and
now working together with B at my client
Roy ler
Holland yeah and the entire data team is
like uh I think eight to nine people we
have half of it is a data engineering
half of it are data
scientist um so first off Roy Flora who
knows about the company yeah oh that's
quite a lot of people actually when I
started working there I had no idea what
the company was I knew that we had a big
flower auction in the Holland I never
knew it was called ho Flor in Holland um
in reality it's really big we start an
auction every single day at 6 o'cl in
the morning and on a daily basis we have
like 100,000 different transactions uh
fun fact about Royal Flora we have eight
different locations so seven of them are
in the Netherlands and one is in uh over
the Border in Ras in Germany but the uh
total size of all of our buildings is
about twice the size of the entire
country of Monaco so it is a quite a big
logistic operation that we're running
there um like I said it is an
international marketplace it is owned by
The Growers and by the buyers of flowers
and plants so uh it is a Cooperative uh
organization and I just to give you a
picture of uh what Flor Holland does
internal inside of the building this was
on the first day that I was at the
office I had no idea what I rent into
because I joined during the co um what
you're going to see here is the
distribution process so this is done on
a daily basis as soon as the auction
starts uh people start buying flowers
and plants and you can uh think about
this as being one of the distribution
areas in alsir and we have three of them
there's a lot of Supply coming in
they're stored in this uh cooling cells
in storage areas and these are our
logistic people that are distribute
Distributing the supply that was sold to
the correct buyer so basically there
will be a whole bunch of caros uh cargo
is out of outside of the
building um yeah then onto our problem
the problem that we're working on it's a
project that serus it was for the
quality control uh people at Royal Flora
this guy that you see here is actually a
person working for the quality control
people he's a very experienced and
knowledgeable guy as you can all see um
what he will do each morning prior to
the auction starting he will go to the
storage area and he will randomly go
past the supply and he will check some
of these Supply items
basically any grower that wants to sell
a product at Royal Flora he needs to
fill in a form and it says this is the
product that that I'm going to sell
these are the product specifications for
example it is a tulip and it is of
quality a or quality B you can imagine
that if you buy something and you pay
for Quality a you want to receive a
quality a
right
so uh daily we have about 15,000 new
products entering our vicinity and also
leaving after the auction so there's a
huge influx of data every single day um
and this guy is only uh this single guy
right there's like five or 20 people
working in quality control they cannot
check all of the supply in our building
so our problem here is really they have
a limited capacity and we have a a
limited people that can check it so what
we want to do is take a data driven
approach to give them the the most risky
Supply to check in order to find the
most faulty uh most percent the highest
percentage of faulty Supply
actually so the idea that we're doing
here is with the same limited Supply
every single day that they're going to
check we want to uh not by random you
could say if you check all of the supply
in the end you will find all faulty
Supply uh of uh uh of the auction but we
want to send them the most risky Supply
and just by checking the same 200 Supply
items we will find more faulty Supply
right with a data driven
approach um how will this work the
general approach a grow will bring a uh
it Supply to Roy flora and one of our
employees will pick up this trolley of
flowers and it will need to decide where
do I need to bring these flowers do they
go to the general storage area or do
they go to the uh cooling cell uh do the
to the inspection Square I mean this
inspection square is a specially
allocated part of the sto storage area
where this quality control people will
walk by and where they will actually
check all of the supply
items
um so as soon as uh it reaches are
building it will make a call to our
application called cus and cus will make
this decision for them um both of the
supply items that are either on the
inspection square or on the general
storage then go into auction and after
auctioning if any buyer finds there's an
issue with the stuff that he bought they
can still give feedback to the quality
control people so the quality control
people know that in hindsight there
actually still was an issue with this
products um in order to do this we
actually figured out we need the three
things within servers first of all
obviously we need to predict some kind
of risk score for each of the supply
items that we have then if we have a
risk score for a supply item we need to
determine does this exceed some kind of
threshold value in order to send it to
the inspection square or send it to the
general storage and that's actually the
uh threshold that we want to set
dynamically because every single day we
have such a huge uh amount of Supply
hitting our building and every single
day we don't know upfront how much
Supply are we're actually uh retrieving
we cannot simply say send all of the
supply with a risk score above 80% or so
to the inspection Square because some
days there will be like 100,000 items
there and some days will only be 10
items right um so in in order to do so
we came up with a solution where we have
a risk score that basically goes up and
down throughout the day depending on how
much Supply we have and how much of the
risky Supply is actually entering our
building um so the first thing that we
need of course for each of our items we
will need to have a risk score we have
set up a simple psych learn pipeline to
train random Forest
classifier um every single day we will
perform our model training on the latest
data so we'll take the data from
yesterday it will rerun uh on the best
parameters that were set and it will
just fit on the latest data so we
basically have the latest data from
yesterday also incorporated into our
current model and every single week we
will run a big hyper parameter search
space using hyper and Spark Tri to uh
perform fine-tuning and model
architecture search on a distributed
spark
cluster the features that we put into
this model are basically uh grower or
product specifications uh combining both
the information about a specific product
because you can think uh tulips might
have a different risk score than uh
roses for example and also specified on
the grower level itself because one
grower can be more risky than other
Growers
right um we will label these by the
observations so that's basically
everything that quality control has
previously seen and found faulty and
also by the reclamations and that is
whenever a buyer has bought something
and has then uh made this feedback call
to the quality control people that there
was an issue with the problem in
hindsight
um all of this this is done over
different uh time frames for example how
much Supply did you have last year what
was the percentage of the supply that
was wrong in the last year and in the
last uh 50 auction dates how many times
did you had something wrong in your
supply that kind of features go into our
model um then we had a risk model so now
we could have risk scores for each of
our supply items which is nice but then
the quality control people with all of
their uh background knowledge said why
are these items actually like high risk
what makes an item high risk right so
what we can also do for each of our
predictions that our model make we can
uh extract the shapely values and with
the shapely values we can simp say how
much does each of our feature values
contribute to our model decision of
making it a risky item or a non-risky
item so this gives us the opportunity to
clearly explain to Quality Control why
an item was selected and also whenever
quality control says hey I think you're
missing out on a feature we can simply
add that feature to the model and then
show them whether this actually had an
impact or not what you see in this
diagram here is the uh prediction for a
single Supply item and then on the left
hand side side is the uh model attribut
attribution for each of our feature
values for class one and then on the
right hand side for class zero so it
turns out and uh your model starts off
of a probability of 0.5 right we don't
know if it's risky or not and then each
of your feature values will basically
shift your model probability for it
being risky either to the left or to the
right it's a really nice way of
explaining a model
actually yeah and then Adam is going to
explain a bit of how we then use our
risk source to actually determine this
threshold right um yeah so uh balker
told us about this cus cus the go the
dog with three hats um if you recall one
was the supply risk the other one is
this Dynamic risk threshold the third
one is the trolley amount so Dynamic
risk threshold is the thing that adjusts
itself throughout the day while the
supply is coming in and it is either
increasing or decreasing and what what
what what what are the uh things here
that make an impact on threshold first
one risk score and we we create a risk
score distribution out of that that's in
the pocket okay we know but what is
changing throughout the day so we may we
are expecting some uh influx of products
right we don't but the issue here is at
with our operations we don't know how
much we're going to receive at the end
of the day and this reflects back on our
remaining capacity because we have
limited capacity we have to be selective
if you're expecting more um more supply
for a given day or uh similarly let's
say we have high capacity at that time
but but then we picked some supplies and
then our remaining capacity is very less
then we we we think okay we have to
bring up a formula such that the risk
threshold adjust itself according to the
influx of the supply and also the
remaining capacity less remaining
capacity should should mean that we
should be more selective Ive so here we
look at uh the chart at the left hand
side to risk distribution uh for a given
day right and then uh the remarks Zone
there is the remaining capacity which is
our capacity we we use for inspection
square and at the right hand side we uh
there is an
integration uh of the of the chart in
the left hand side um integration
starting from the high
score um so in this example I'll just uh
uh go along with the with the line here
and explain what is happening when the
remaining capacity is changing so let's
assume that the remaining remaining
capacity is
decreasing this means we're just moving
along the line the blue line to the
downward area this causes the risk score
to go up this is expected of course
because the the distribution chart the
integration of it it's monotonously
decreasing which causes the risk score
to um uh the the threshold to go higher
up so the next
example
yep similar chart but the the same
distribution it's just uh shifted above
why because we are expecting more
trolley for that given day so more
trolly amounts right um so uh for the
same capacity if we expecting more uh
Supply to come in what happens more
amount of riskier items right that that
means we have to be more selective again
that means we should adjust the uh
Dynamic threshold in real time to a
higher one it's indeed the reason why we
see the threshold going to the right
means it's
increasing so so far we talked about the
first hat Supply risk
B me the second had Dynamic risk
threshold which is adjusted uh in real
time uh throughout the
day and we talked about the trolly
amount that is also being uh updated
throughout the day but how we do this
with forecasting uh with a machine
learning based
model uh so at every like any moment in
the day we trying to well we we have an
expectation of how many trolleys are
going to arrive uh for for the holid day
right and uh for that we use the recent
data the amount of trolleys that have uh
been delivered until then also some time
specific features like time based
features and location and Zone specific
features based on the
we have a very similar to set Sim
similar setup as to what we have for
Supply risk um predictions like we have
daily retraining with fresh data and a
model selection process with hyperopt uh
every week
um what is different for trolley
forecasting though like uh from the Ops
point of view we have to deploy this uh
in a real time real real-time
environment so that's deployed deployed
in an endpoint because this has to be a
reactive
component all right so we we talked
about the idea the approach uh how do
these come
together um I'll name a few tools that
we use in our uh text
stack uh so we use uh P spark for data
Transformations AWS um for as a like a
cloud platform uh data braks indeed
Unity catalog for data storage hyper op
for hyper parameter tuning Mal flow for
storing our models uh and logging uh
purposes um slack and grafana for
alerting uh
purposes um what else I think it these
all covered basically and of course
airflow for for the orchestration of our
jobs um so
uh baa will be explaining more about our
training process of ml upsite um how
would you like to do yeah yeah sure yeah
because uh ml upset is the thing that
everybody likes nowadays right uh you
can do machine learning but having it in
practice you also need to know how are
you doing and uh how is it doing while
it is running in real time um so as Adam
said we have airflow which basically is
our orchestrator it will uh fire off our
jobs on data bricks um first off that
you can see that there's two different
flows that we have we have the top flow
that will be for our risk model so we
will fetch our supply dat every single
day we will fetch our labels of course
and we will combine that in a pice Park
job so now that we have our data we can
pre-process it for the risk models
extract all of the uh feature values
that we need that go into our model we
we can train our model and then we use
ml flow to store our model and also
store uh metrics that we have on a a
holdout test set during training so in
that way if the metrics on our on our
training uh will somehow deviate from
what we expect we can immediately alert
into uh SL back and then somebody can
pick up on that and see hey the model is
drifting or something like that um after
the trolley uh after the risk model has
been trained we will do a batch
inference task so for all of the
potential buyers and uh suppliers and
all of the potential Supply items we
will predict a risk core and we simply
store that into RDS
database um similarly to this we do this
for trolley forecasting uh the
difference here is that for trolley
forecasting we will uh not do a batch
inference but we will uh deploy on a
inference endpoint on data bricks so
then we basically have an API that we
can qu uh call throughout the day in
real time for each of the supply items
that hit our building uh Now give me uh
the latest updated trolley forecast for
this
day
um yeah really important thing to note
here and uh also the ml oping we have
this feedback loop so after we have
performed training and stored both our
models in a mail flow and either on an
endpoint or have a batch inference with
them we will monitor also how the model
from yesterday did so with the latest
data from today we can check our model
that we had deployed yesterday how did
it predict in real time yesterday now
that we have the labels for yesterday
because yesterday the auction was
finished people have either reclaimed
their items they need have do that
within 24 hours and the quality control
people have checked all the items so we
know did our model prediction makes
sense right if any of that is wrong or
there anything off we will see it in
grafana where we have some real life
dashboards showing uh the inference
stuff the trading stuff and uh uh
grafana will send an alert to a slack
Channel where one of our team members
can pick up on it they can either uh
trigger model retraining or dive into
what is going on here um the one more
thing that we do here during model
training we use hyperopt which is
actually really nice you don't have to
do a huge grid search which is really
expensive but hyperopt is a way of doing
a basan search over this grid search uh
over this grd grid and uh we will run
that in a spark truck so that's
basically distributed on a cluster
because it's such a large data set right
so we have this in place we now have our
model training we have a model uh
monitoring and now I think the next
slide is for inference yeah yes indeed
so we have a training so far and but the
real time adjustment of dynamic
threshold happens in endpoint as told
earlier so uh yeah so well when whenever
a supply comes in then we have to make a
decision whether it should go to an
inspection square or not and for that to
happen we need uh like a few things one
is what is the trolley amount expected
okay we have it from the uh trolley
forecast uh model which is deployed in
data break serving
endpoint um the other two things are
what is the risk score distribution that
we are expecting and what is the risk
score for for the given item right which
we we we access them from the Amazon RDS
um right and um like similar to what we
had for training if there is any issue
for with latency of the endpoint or
similar then we alert these in a select
Channel or
grafana all right so um all said we we
talked about the idea approach the
architecture but this thing is happening
for real and how well are we doing so
the initial like the base Baseline model
we had was random selection model but we
the the kpi was to okay how do we uh
assure for the same
capacity uh to pick more faulty items
right this was the the uh the kpi that
we had and we run a couple of back tests
this is also running in one of our
auction locations for a month now um so
random um selection model could manage
for our inti initial capacity around 2
and a
half% and uh with this model driven
approach uh data dur approach we uh we
we can achieve around 8 and a half 9% uh
recall at uh K and uh so Royal Flora
currently actually has uh something
better than of course the random
selection method it's a rule based
approach and uh like they can manage
around three and a half and 4% with it
it lays somewhere between these two
lines so yeah we're happy that we
managed to get our kpis
succeeded right so um we prepared uh an
animation to show you how the risk
threshold behaves in real
time let's see if this
works all right right it works so uh
each dot here represents uh a supply
coming in and this is uh from a data uh
from the real data but a sub sample of
it so we see we let's go back once more
should
yes so as the supply comes in we see
that the the risk threshold adjust
itself according to the remaining
capacity or the trolley amount expected
for this case we see that it's uh rising
in time and this is probably due to the
trolley forecast uh getting higher over
time or the remaining capacity obviously
decreasing so uh the advantage of that
is for us and what we wanted to build
earlier in the day let's pick that samp
around
8:00 that that sample has been picked
for inspection Square because it's
laying above the risk threshold
obviously but that wouldn't have been
selected if it arrived later on uh this
was kind of kind of the expected
behavior that we wanted to have we kind
of achieved it one thing though the
remaining capacity is uh currently it's
not decreasing hour that's something to
improve in the operational side and then
then we're I think expecting to have
more more of an adjustment like like an
increase or a decrease
uh and uh some more details about our
setup obviously it's uh in reality what
we uh managed to uh to build is slightly
more complex than what we described here
this is uh currently running for eight
Auction location like we have a we have
the the the product running for eight
auction locations and uh six storage
types right uh per each Auction location
currently being tested like uh for
almost a month at one of the auction
locations for
real and uh one more thing so um
everything we built so far in
curus uh was uh data driven yes but we
wanted to make it possible for each uh
supplier to be picked at any time so we
we put a random component into it and
reserved 10% of the whole capacity
always to be selected with a random
selection model so that uh a bias is
avoided so uh that's all from my side
our side uh thank you for listening to
our talk about the enhanced quality
control do you have any
[Applause]
questions
yeah so uh thanks for the cool talk uh
first of all and um is this now running
in production and uh if so uh are there
any interesting uh facts or biases that
you have found due to the random
selection running next to the model
anything any knobs you had to
tweak yeah so it is running in
production and we are currently
monitoring how it goes uh so the random
selection is just the 10% of the
allocated space right so there's like
200 slots allocated for selecting and 10
of them will be random and the
interesting fact that we need to monitor
but we are not monitoring yet because it
has gone into production like last week
uh it takes a while for these things to
integrate apparently in a big
organization um but yeah it will be
interesting to see if we do better on
this random sampling and also we want to
retrain our model or fine tune the model
basically on all of the stuff that we
now have in the inspection Square
because currently we're basically blind
we would only know the labels from the
supply that was actually sent back to us
or checked by these guys and now we can
actually uh uh control what we sent into
the random sample as well and then
verify or whether or not it is a faulty
supply thank you I wanted to ask about
the bias but then you answered it in the
last slide but I had another question so
you mentioned that the recall went from
Two and a Half to
eight% but does that tell me that so a
lot of people send back the flowers that
are poor
quality half% bels to random selection
mod were to run a back test on with a
random selection model and average oops
sorry sorry yeah so 2 and a half% was
based on the uh like Baseline model like
the the random selection model that we
had uh for initial capacity around let's
say 200 right okay 200 so um so that's
just like a baseline thing that we
compare with and uh the real comparison
that we had was what Roy Flora had in
that place with the basic rules it was
around 4% and uh what we managed with
the state approach was 8 and a half to
9ish just to add to that so this is the
recall at K value like see it as an
information retrieval thing where you
have a list of items and you'll uh do
your recall at K so it's only over the
top 200 items so it's not 8% of all
Supply that was sold but 8% over the 200
that we had
checked so this is not this doesn't
generalize to all Supply
basically
do do you have any idea what the real
values could be because you do not know
how much of the real Supply is
faulty well actually not we know how
many uh things get reclaimed uh I don't
know it out of the top of my head the
quality control definitely does um but
the fact of the matter is previously
there was no like Insight in how things
were selected it was just the experience
of these guys hey I know this grower
this grower often makes mistakes so I'll
just check him again uh so the random
sampling wasn't too rampling um but of
how much of a supply gets sent back I I
wouldn't know that out of the top of my
head we have we have room for one or two
more
questions did you get feedback from the
the quality control Personnel
already you want to say something about
don't
worry yeah so uh we had a couple of
meetings before uh releasing this
product computers will take our jobs
that's that's yeah yeah well like uh
this was one of the biggest lessons we
learned right so whenever you uh try to
publish any product a digital digital
product that have some kind of attach to
a humans operation they want to be uh
notified you know like earlier and they
want to understand what is going on uh
so uh one of the feedbacks was okay what
what are the features that we are using
for for our risk uh uh risk prediction
uh right uh model okay and then uh they
came up with a few ideas um of course
not all of them them are feasible for us
to implement like what is going on in
Africa these days and they thought like
it has some impact maybe it does but
it's not feasible at that moment for us
to implement then we skip that but uh
all in all is the idea is not to make
everyone happy at the same time it's
about like having this product rolled
out in an interactive manner so uh we
thinks that things are not going uh like
as good as expected okay we had new
features or we just watched how the the
the product is going
okay I think time is almost up so thank
thanks a
[Applause]
[Music]
lot